Un chasseur sachant chasser sans
son chien est un bon chasseur.
Piano, panier, piano, panier,
piano, panier.
Pruneau cuit, pruneau cru,
pruneau cuit, pruneau cru...
C'est mon bassin.
Je l'ai bousculé.
Je le range.
Pétunia, pétunia.
Bonjour, c'est moi.
Tom Slansky.
Et cette nuit pourrait être la plus
marquante de mon existence.
Pourquoi, me demanderez-vous ?
Avez-vous déjà entendu
parler de...
Vampires ?
« Non, Tom. Ils n'existent pas.
C'est une légende. »
Va te f...
Désolé, Maman.
Pour le « va te f... ».
Je me présente :
je suis en deuxième année
à l'université Hawthorne
où j'étudie la photo.
Mon sujet photo préféré
est la silhouette féminine.
Mais ce film ne parle pas de moi.
C'est l'histoire de Docteur G.,
le plus grand prof
d'Histoire de tous les temps.
Et vous savez quoi ?
C'est un vampire.
« Un vampire qui enseigne l'Histoire ?
Comme c'est rocambolesque ! »
Va te f... à la fin !
Il y a bien longtemps,
Docteur G. tomba amoureux
d'une humaine nommée Mary.
Prenez une chambre !
Un jour, ils étaient
dans la chambre de Mary.
La nuit tombait, mais ils s'en
moquaient. Ils se tripotaient.
Et quand le soleil se coucha,
il la mordit.
Il avait tué l'amour de sa vie.
Tout le monde était furax.
Sa famille refusa qu'il assiste
aux obsèques.
Tout ça parce qu'il l'avait tuée.
Comme c'est un génie,
il se déguisa en moine
pour se faufiler à l'intérieur.
Voleur !
Gretzky !
Je ne voulais pas
lui faire de mal.
Tu es le diable en personne,
déguisé en homme d'Église.
Ne fais pas l'idiot, Gregor.
Tu pourriras en enfer,
Wayne Gretzky.
Tu pourriras en enfer.
J'y suis déjà.
Vous avez vu ? Il a descendu
Gregor, mais pas avec ses crocs.
Depuis la mort de Mary,
il n'arrivait plus à les sortir.
Adieu, Mary.
C'est ainsi que
depuis trois siècles,
Docteur G. parcourt le monde
avec ses crocs défaillants,
se nourrissant exclusivement
de sang animal.
Du moins, jusqu'à
il y a quelques mois.
L'impuissance du vampire peut
s'apparenter à celle de l'homme.
Je ne suis pas impuissant.
Tes crocs ne sortent plus.
Comment tu appelles ça ?
Cette comparaison
pourrait nous aider.
En quoi ?
Tu es impuissant depuis que
tu as tué l'amour de ta vie.
Navré, Herman.
Un hémophile.
Tu salueras Mary.
Non. Il n'est pas rare
qu'un meurtrier
devienne impuissant.
Car en général...
Bon sang ! Qu'est-ce qui
ne tourne pas rond chez toi ?
C'était peut-être mieux
quand on n'était qu'amis.
Mieux pour qui ? Pas pour toi.
Tu as besoin d'aide.
Mais personne n'a d'expérience
dans ce domaine.
J'en ai avec les gens et pour moi,
tu ressembles à une personne.
Et si je fais bien mon boulot,
tu ressembleras plus à un démon.
- On ne leur ressemble pas.
- Dans Buffy, si.
En vrai, non.
Soit ! J'ai encore à apprendre.
Les documents sur ton espèce
sont rares. Ma seule référence,
c'est la culture pop.
Quoi qu'il en soit, je suis heureux
que tu te sois confié à moi.
Moi aussi.
Qui est le conseiller de Chris ?
Le Professeur Levine, je crois.
Ce type sent le pain maison.
J'ai attrapé un derche
à grande bouche.
Plutôt une queue à grande bouche.
Quoi ?
- Où est ta copine ?
- C'est pas ma copine.
Avoue qu'elle n'existe pas
et que la nuit, vous virez gays.
Avoue que tu sens la merde
toute la journée.
Quoi ?
Je vais attendre dans la voiture.
Désolée. J'ai oublié mon chapeau.
- Sale garce !
- Chris.
Non, Ted.
Elle a raison.
C'est légitime d'hésiter
sur sa spécialité en première
année. C'est dur de savoir
ce qu'on va faire
de sa vie quand...
- on a 18 ans.
- J'en ai 19.
- Vous avez redoublé ?
- Qu'insinuez-vous ?
Développez.
Quand on parle du vampire !
Du loup !
C'est pas un vampire.
Je viens de lire Twilight.
Depuis, les vampires m'obsèdent.
C'était le docteur Gretzky,
qui est un excellent professeur
d'Histoire, pas un vampire.
Il m'a semblé effrayé.
Il l'était.
Mais de façon positive.
Les étudiants l'adorent.
Apparemment, les vampires
peuvent copuler toute la nuit.
- Vous aimez bien Edward ?
- Je ne lis pas cette merde.
- Ton langage !
- Quoi ? À la fac,
on a le droit de dire merde.
Elle a raison. Certains enseignants
emploient ce mot en cours.
C'est honteux.
Vous avez raison.
Je vais régler ça.
Assez bavardé.
- Tu devrais te lâcher, papa.
- Je n'aime pas ce langage.
Je le sais,
mais je suis à la fac !
Tu es superbe.
- Sympa, tes cheveux !
- Je les ai coupés.
- Ça te va bien.
- Pas assez.
- M. Keller.
- Je t'en prie !
Navré. Ted.
Les mecs, je vous présente Chris
et son père, Ted.
Ce sont mes potes de fraternité.
Voici Jared...
Kyle...
et Tom.
C'est un réel plaisir
de vous rencontrer.
Je dois y aller, ma puce.
- Prends soin de ma fille.
- Je me la ferai.
Je le ferai.
Je veillerai sur elle.
Chris, tu intègres une sororité ?
Oui, les Kappa Omicron.
Les Kappa O sont
de grosses salopes !
C'est quoi, votre fraternité ?
- On est des STD.
- Ça veut dire MST en anglais.
Sigma Tau Delta.
La Merveille.
Il a un parapluie ?
A cause d'une maladie
cutanée. Il est trop cool.
- C'est le professeur Gretzky.
- C'est lui ?
Oui, il enseigne l'histoire.
Je t'ai conseillé son cours.
Tu as bien fait. Tout le monde
l'adore, selon mon conseiller.
- Il est génial.
- Ton conseiller t'en a parlé ?
Quand Gretzky est passé
à son bureau, il a dit :
- « quand on parle du vampire ».
- Quand on parle du vampire ?
Bienvenue en Histoire.
Je suis le professeur Gretzky.
Des nouveaux ?
- Je dois être populaire.
- Monsieur Gretzky ?
Votre nom est un hommage
à Wayne Gretzky ?
Je m'appelais Wayne Gretzky
bien avant que Wayne Gretzky
ne soit nommé ainsi.
Il est plus âgé que vous.
Il doit avoir 50 ans.
Mon nom n'est pas un hommage.
Il aimerait bien.
Il ne faisait pas encore partie
de la NHL quand je suis né.
Si c'est pas une coïncidence !
Ça va aller.
- Désolé.
- Ce n'est rien.
On va étudier des coïncidences.
En Histoire.
Tu as mis ta fille
hors d'elle tout à l'heure.
Je ne changerai pas mes croyances
parce qu'elle entre à la fac.
Puisqu'on aborde le sujet...
Tu vois Ron, de l'épicerie bio ?
Il est Amish et dit que les Amish
peuvent s'exposer au soleil.
Et il a des miroirs.
On n'aime pas être photographiés.
- Tu vas à la messe.
- Ma mère était catholique !
Tu n'es pas Amish,
je n'y crois pas.
Plus depuis des années.
Que suis-je, selon toi ?
Je m'en moque.
Je mets ça sur le compte
d'une légère névrose.
Je préfère laisser couler.
Mais tu sais quoi ? Tu vas finir
par rompre le lien avec ta fille.
Ted, il y a des choses en moi
que je ne peux pas changer.
Et dont je n'aime pas parler.
Tu devrais me comprendre.
Que veux-tu dire ?
Depuis quand
tu ne me touches plus ?
Tu es injuste.
Rassure-toi. Je mets ça sur
le compte d'une légère névrose.
Donc il sectionne le bras de
l'homme, mais ne s'en sert pas
pour le frapper.
Il le gifle de sa propre main.
Gengis avait
un fabuleux sens de l'humour.
C'est lors des rapports
physiques qu'il riait le plus.
Un jour, je me souviens,
quand j'étais...
d'après les témoignages...
il était avec une femme
qui avait une jambe plus courte.
En enlevant la botte de
cette jambe, il éclata de rire.
Tous les hommes à proximité
se mirent à rire.
On a tous... ils ont tous regardé
et vu que Gengis
avait enfilé la botte.
Il me manque.
Façon de parler. Ça me manque
de lire des textes sur lui.
Continuez vos lectures.
C'est vrai,
je pourrais, mais...
ça ne serait plus pareil.
Ça ne serait plus aussi drôle.
Que quoi ?
Ce sera à l'exam ?
Oui, comme tout ce que je dis.
Je plaisante. Pas ça.
- Mais c'est de l'Histoire !
- C'est vrai. C'est de l'Histoire.
Je voulais vous dire que...
j'ai beaucoup aimé
votre devoir du semestre dernier
sur l'impuissance
chez les meurtriers.
Merci.
A vrai dire,
j'y ai beaucoup appris.
Vraiment ?
Pas sur moi, bien sûr.
- À mardi.
- Entendu.
Au revoir.
Bonjour.
- Quand on parle du vampire ?
- Navré, j'étais confus.
J'avais vexé une étudiante.
Ça m'a échappé.
Et le secret professionnel ?
Je sais, mais comme si
quelqu'un allait y croire !
On en reparlera.
J'ai cours.
- Quel est ton temps au 40 yards ?
- De quoi parles-tu ?
Si j'étais un vampire,
je ferais partie de la NFL.
Tu serais un bon free safety.
Lorraine veut faire une nouvelle
collecte de sang. Je préfèrerais
- une collecte de plasma.
- C'est quoi ?
Tu es la fille la plus cool
que je connaisse.
Tu n'as pas peur
de poser des questions.
Tu connais...
Regardez ! Il y a La Merveille.
Bizarre.
Je ne me contrôlais plus
comme avec Mary. Le jour,
je me maîtrisais,
mais à la nuit tombée...
c'était fini.
Trois siècles
d'impuissance, quelques séances
avec moi... Sans être guéri,
- tout de même !
- Qui est-elle ?
Elle est ton viagra
pour vampire.
Tu crois ?
Et moi, je suis ton érection
de quatre heures.
Du moins, jusqu'à ce que
tu sortes les crocs tout seul.
Je n'ai pas montré les crocs.
J'ai plutôt ressenti un...
- picotement.
- Picotement, fourmillement...
Si tu t'étais attardé, la fac
entière crèverait de trouille.
Elle lui ressemblait.
- Ça ne m'étonne pas.
- Vraiment ?
On voit tant de visages que tu étais
obligé de recroiser le sien.
Un jour, j'ai traité une femme
qui était le portrait craché
de ma seconde épouse.
J'ai failli perdre
le droit d'exercer.
Mais elle en valait la peine.
Tout comme cette belle plante.
C'est étrange de vous voir
sans Tom.
Le soir, il va chez le coiffeur.
Ce n'était pas possible.
- C'est dommage.
- Oui.
Dites...
Quand vous êtes entré dans
le bâtiment, je vous ai vu tomber.
Oui. C'est parce que...
ma tête bourdonnait.
Content que vous alliez mieux.
Vous sembliez paniqué.
Je hais les bourdons.
- Monsieur Gretzky ?
- Oui ?
Vous êtes ?
Je suis Chris Keller.
Je ne suis pas sur vos listes.
J'aimerais savoir si...
je peux vous prendre
devant la classe ?
Si je peux vous prendre
dans ma classe ?
- C'est possible ?
- Oui ! Bien sûr.
Excusez-moi.
Je viens d'apprendre
le décès de ma mère.
Le cours est fini.
- Il a pété un plomb, le pauvre.
- Oui.
Docteur G. !
Que... ?
Je sens votre souffle.
Vous êtes gay ?
Pauvre Barry.
Pauvre petit pédé.
Je vous en apporte un.
Une fois qu'elle aura pris
le rythme des cours,
elle aura plus de temps
pour le reste.
Pourvu que Docteur G.
l'admette dans sa classe !
Quand on parle du vampire !
Chris nous a répété ce qu'avait
dit Levine. Quel con !
N'est-ce pas ?
En réalité, il est cool
et tout le bordel.
Vous dites des grossièretés ?
En général, j'évite.
Ça sonnait bien.
Vous tenez le choc ?
Comment ça ?
- Avec le décès de votre mère...
- Ce n'est pas grave.
Ça fait des années
qu'elle est morte.
Ou plutôt qu'elle était
mourante. Je m'y attendais.
Vous paraissiez bouleversé
en quittant la salle.
Ils voulaient lui
prélever ses organes.
Mon amie Chris est très motivée
par votre cours.
Chris Keller ?
Oui. Elle est brillante sans faire
intello. Elle est gentille.
Je suis sûr qu'elle vous plaira.
Pas dans un sens sexuel.
Vous l'apprécierez, c'est tout.
Surtout pas de sexe !
Bien. Il faut que j'aille...
me préparer pour...
mes étudiants.
Pas dans un sens sexuel.
Pour les cours.
Cette fois, j'y vais.
Vous deux, je vous vois...
plus tard.
Sexuellement.
Surtout pas de sexe !
Entrez !
Oui ?
Vous m'avez eu !
Je suis vraiment désolée.
J'avais prévu de...
surgir dans votre bureau
en criant « tada ! », mais...
j'ai dit votre nom.
Dommage que
je ne m'appelle pas « tada » !
Ce n'est pas tout,
vous feriez mieux d'y aller.
Enfin, après une brève
mais néanmoins agréable minute.
Ou deux. Mais ensuite...
Navré. Sans vouloir être impoli,
j'ai des cours à préparer.
Ce que tu es belle !
Tu l'as toujours été.
Pardon ?
Beau lapsus !
Qu'avez-vous dit ?
J'ai dit : « beau lapsus ! »
Non. Juste avant ça.
Je n'ai rien dit.
Je l'ai ramassé quand
vous vous êtes sauvé du cours.
Je l'ai lavé.
C'est triste pour votre maman.
Toute cette histoire a été
assez pénible.
- Ça recommence !
- Wayne ? Vous allez bien ?
Non ! Je me suis pissé dessus.
- Quoi ?
- Sortez !
Revenez demain.
D'accord. A quelle heure ?
Le matin ! Le matin, c'est bien.
J'adore !
- Qui sera ta première victime ?
- Je ne sais pas.
Le courant est bien passé
avec la copine de Fred.
Arrête tes conneries.
Elle ne t'appartient pas.
Tente le coup ou passe ta route.
Je n'ai eu que deux jours.
Lâchez-moi.
Je dis seulement qu'elle a envie
de moi et que tu es égoïste.
Sans blague,
que préférera-t-elle regarder ?
Mes fesses nues
ou le cul flasque de Tom tombant
du lit du dessus ?
Ni l'un ni l'autre ! Connard !
Je plaisante !
Je passe.
J'ai encore gagné, pétasses.
Souillon, la porte.
Maintenant.
Coucou ! J'apporte
des boissons.
- De l'alcool ?
- Des boissons énergisantes.
Excusez-moi.
C'est sa mère ?
- Plutôt sa sœur jumelle.
- Elle est trop canon.
- Il est deux heures du matin.
- Je voulais te surprendre.
Comment ? En montrant à toutes
mes copines que tu es bizarre ?
Je ne pouvais pas dormir.
Comme d'habitude. Je déteste
tes conneries Amish.
Il y a parfois une raison
aux conneries Amish des gens.
Si tu tiens tant à ta religion,
tu aurais dû me la transmettre.
J'ai toujours voulu t'enseigner
nos coutumes, seulement...
j'ignorais comment.
- Mais je peux encore essayer.
- Non, tu ne peux plus.
J'ai 19 ans, c'est trop tard.
Je n'en ai plus rien à faire.
Merci pour les boissons.
On a des Monster, les grognasses.
Tu crois que les Kappa O
sont de grosses salopes ?
Tu as vu leur clip sur YouTube ?
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait avec elles ?
Bonsoir, chérie.
Jolies chaussures.
Tu es allée voir Chris ?
- Oui, je lui ai rendu visite.
- Ça a été ?
Lamentable.
- Chérie !
- Toi, tu es proche d'elle.
Elle me déteste. Fais-moi
un procès !
Tu n'aimerais pas...
remonter le temps ?
De beaucoup ?
Plus que ça.
M. Gretzky ?
Oui, lui-même. Entrez donc !
Encore vous ?
Vous m'aviez dit
de passer ce matin.
En effet.
Que puis-je pour vous ?
La fiche d'inscription tardive.
Tristement célèbre auparavant.
Le précieux sésame.
Pour être franc avec vous,
le cours du soir est complet.
Mais...
une place s'est libérée
dans celui du matin.
Celui de 10h30 ?
Il semblerait que Barry Pearson
était inscrit à ce cours,
mais il est porté disparu.
Oui, c'est affreux.
Terrible.
Mais quand Dieu ouvre une porte,
il ouvre aussi une fenêtre.
Et à présent, vous pouvez
vous inscrire à mon cours.
Merci.
J'espère n'avoir enfreint
aucune règle.
Quelle règle ?
Qui fait les règles ?
Je l'ignore.
Bon...
À bientôt en cours.
O.K. Je vous chercherai.
Entendu.
Je serai le prof.
Pervers !
C'est pour les cours.
Perverse toi-même !
Voilà Chris !
- Invite-la à la soirée.
- J'allais le faire.
- Salut ! Ça va ?
- Salut.
T'es inscrite au cours de Gretzky ?
Oui, mais celui du soir était
complet. J'ai eu une place
- dans celui du matin.
- Cool, c'est le mien !
Fred Pierrafeu !
Tu étais censé l'attraper.
Ça fait mal, connard.
Moi aussi, je t'adore.
Et puisqu'on parle d'adorer...
Chris, tu es adorable.
J'adore ton odeur.
J'ai été ravi de te voir, Chris.
Pas de cochonneries
dans mon lit ce soir, les pédés.
- A plus tard.
- Comme si ça arrivait.
Quand vas-tu
l'inviter à la soirée ?
- De quoi tu parles ?
- Chris ?
« La plus belle fille
que j'aie jamais vue ».
- Mec...
- De quoi parlez-vous ?
De banalités.
Juste de banalités.
Tu veux m'inviter ?
Je file, j'ai des livres
à acheter. À plus tard.
On se voit en cours.
Tu m'expliques ?
Je voulais te parler d'elle,
mais étrangement,
ça m'est revenu quand Jared
et Kyle se sont cassés.
Tu aurais pu attendre qu'elle parte.
Je suis vraiment désolé.
Je suis aussi surpris que toi.
Tout individu qui entrait dans
cette chambre sans être annoncé
était exécuté sur le champ
à l'épée ou à l'arbalète.
Heureusement
pour Guenièvre, la lune était
pleine en cette nuit fatidique.
Donc...
Vous êtes Guenièvre.
Alors que Lancelot dormait nu...
J'enlève ceci.
Je rigole. Je vous épargne ça.
Alors que Lancelot dormait nu,
il tendit la main vers son épée
quand la lune éclaira Guenièvre,
dévoilant son visage pâle
aux taches de rousseur à peine marquées.
C'est à cet instant et en ce lieu
que Lancelot sut
qu'il était prêt à tout perdre :
son pouvoir, son titre, son rang,
pour cette seule
nuit interdite,
pour cette longue
et compromettante nuit
avec cette Bethsabée rousse.
Camelot n'est pas une légende ?
Vous apprendrez dans mon cours
que chaque légende
commence par une vérité.
Et qu'un vrai héros doit être
prêt à tout perdre pour obtenir
ce qu'il désire.
Bien.
Bethsabée rousse, à votre place.
Lancelot était nu,
le prof a un pantalon.
On reprend le cours.
Vous la réparez ?
En fait, je viens de la casser.
Vous voulez arrêter l'Histoire
après un seul cours ?
Ce cours était...
il m'a beaucoup parlé.
Je n'arrête pas d'y penser.
Vous savez,
ce qui est drôle, c'est que...
c'est une histoire d'amour
souvent mal interprétée.
Ce que beaucoup ignorent
au sujet du roi Arthur,
c'est que c'était un vrai...
connard.
Génial, non ?
Certains trouveront ça dégueu
à cause de la différence d'âge.
S'ils savaient leur vrai écart
d'âge, ils se vomiraient dessus.
Je suis fier de Docteur G.
Il y a deux femmes au monde qui
ressemblent à Chris et sa mère,
et ce sont Chris et sa mère.
Et il a couché avec les deux.
Les frôler dans le foule serait
déjà le pied pour Fred et moi.
Le seul problème,
c'est que Fred a souffert.
Vas-y, fais-le.
Freddie Prinze Jr...
Tu es lourd avec tes surnoms
de merde.
Cul sec.
Comment prends-tu
personnellement...
le fait que Chris se tape
Docteur G. ? Par curiosité.
Pas si mal vu que c'est la rumeur
la plus débile
- que j'ai entendue.
- On sait tous qu'ils le font.
Ils s'enferment dans son bureau.
Ça ne prouve pas qu'ils baisent.
Ça pourrait.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
On dit ça pour t'aider.
Tu seras moins surpris
si tu la vois sur ma liste.
Sa liste de conquêtes sexuelles.
Ça n'arrivera sûrement pas !
Vous êtes trop cons.
Finissons-les.
Tout le monde sait que tu t'envoies
en l'air. Pourquoi le nier ?
Parce que c'est pas vos oignons !
Tu vas le voir son bureau
tous les jours.
Oui, pour parler du cours.
- Avec nos pantalons sur nous.
- Ou plutôt, l'un sur l'autre.
Comme si vous les échangiez.
On a échangé nos pantalons.
Le sexe, c'est dément !
Il y a de bons moments.
Tu me conduis
chez le chiropracteur ?
A douze ans, elle a dit a son père
qu'elle voudrait m'épouser.
- Comment le sais-tu ?
- Il me l'a dit.
- Quand on parle du vampire !
- Docteur G. ?
Il est avec Chris.
- Montre.
- Cet appareil m'a coûté cher.
Elle monte dans sa voiture.
Docteur G. se tape
ta dulcinée, mec !
Ce n'est pas ma dulcinée.
C'est la dulcinée de personne.
Il n'y a rien entre eux.
Elle est montée avec lui
dans sa bagnole.
Elle peut monter dans une voiture
sans coucher avec son proprio.
J'en sais quelque chose.
Penses-y deux minutes.
Docteur G. se tape ma dulcinée.
Depuis combien de temps
te tapes-tu cette fille ?
Quelques jours.
Cinq semaines, peut-être.
Tu me prends pour un clown ?
Pourquoi tu ne m'as rien dit ?
C'est une de mes élèves.
Et c'est une gosse.
Et maintenant, tu sors
les crocs comme en 1399.
En gros, oui.
Tu me les montres ?
Dans ton bureau ?
Je dois te poser une question.
A part Barry,
combien de personnes
as-tu tuées ?
Aucune ! Je ne te demande pas
d'aide pour tuer.
Dieu soit loué ! Je suis heureux
de t'entendre dire ça.
Je redoutais ta réponse. Tu m'ôtes
un poids de la conscience.
Sauf que...
tu sais, au départ...
pourquoi voulais-tu
retrouver tes crocs ?
J'espérais me sentir mieux.
J'avais occulté les meurtres.
Soyons clair :
à la Renaissance, je saignais
des gens à cause de leur démarche.
Puis j'ai rencontré Mary...
et mes besoins ont changé.
Je vois.
Tu ne veux ni tuer, ni jouer en NFL.
Que veux-tu ?
Eh bien...
Tu essaies de m'aider
à me sentir mieux ?
Tu devras la laisser s'en aller
un jour ou l'autre. Tu le sais ?
Regarde-toi. Tu sors les crocs.
Tu te sens comme jamais depuis
trois siècles. Tout va bien.
J'éprouve ça parce que...
quand je suis avec Chris,
il y a des moments où,
l'espace d'une seconde, c'est
comme si Mary était encore là,
que je ne l'avais pas tuée.
Une fois le moment passé,
elle est toujours morte.
« Je m'éveillai. Elle s'enfuit.
Et le jour me ramena à ma nuit. »
Qu'est-ce que je fiche avec
une Lolita de 19 ans ?
Moins que ce que je ferais.
Cette fille t'a amené jusque là.
Vois où ça te conduit.
Salut, étrangère.
Salut !
Ça faisait un bail.
Il s'est passé tant de choses.
Comment un truc pareil
peut-il arriver ?
Eh bien...
Un jour, j'étais dans son bureau.
J'ai enlevé mon manteau et...
- J'étais nue au-dessous.
- Pourquoi tu me racontes ça ?
Parce que tu es le seul
à qui je peux
en parler.
Une autre fois, dans son bureau,
on était plutôt intimes...
Tu couchais avec lui.
Mais tout du long, je ne pensais
qu'à toi.
Non, ce n'est pas ça.
Je ne pense pas
- à toi de cette façon.
- Moi non plus.
C'était de la mémoire
musculaire.
- De quoi ?
- D'autre chose.
En fait...
j'imaginais qu'à la fac,
rien ne serait plus pareil.
Qu'on glanderait, qu'on
picolerait, ce genre de trucs.
Que j'allais être une étudiante
ordinaire, pas que...
je baiserais comme une dingue
avec mon professeur.
Que me conseilles-tu ?
Largue-le.
Et vite avant de changer d'avis.
- Mec, viens voir.
- Quoi ?
Ramène-toi.
Il faut que tu voies ça.
C'est Chris, et alors ?
- Quand on l'a vue avec Docteur G.
- Merci de me le rappeler.
Non, regarde ! Il y a Chris,
le parapluie de Docteur G.,
- mais lui n'est pas là.
- Mince, Tom !
Rajoute-moi dessus pour que
je me sente encore plus débile.
Je ne l'ai pas retouchée.
Si tu le dis.
J'ai un QCM là-dessus.
Évite de faire du bruit.
Là, il y a le parapluie.
Chris est là. Où est Docteur G. ?
Je ne suis pas aussi doué
pour les retouches. Je t'assure.
Preuve C.
Là, il y a Chris, le parapluie,
mais pas de Docteur G.
Pourquoi n'apparaît-il pas
sur les photos ?
Vos cheveux sont à peine
plus foncés que les siens,
qui étaient coupés aux épaules.
Marilyn mesurait 1,66 m
quand elle se tenait droite.
JFK faisait 1,82 m. Elle aimait
donc porter des talons hauts
quand elle allait au Bureau ovale
pour le regarder dans les yeux.
Mais cette liaison
pesait à JFK.
Il aimait sa femme. Marilyn
n'était qu'une distraction,
un moyen d'oublier Castro.
Ça va ? Vous voulez de l'eau ?
Ça va. Un peu de toux.
Les jours raccourcissent.
Dépêche-toi.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le soleil
va se coucher ?
A croire que tu es un loup-garou
ou je ne sais quoi.
Toujours partante
pour le cinéma demain ?
Si c'est encore un film
de Woody Allen, vas-y sans moi.
Ça me saoûle, ces rencards de
vieux. On pourrait sortir le soir
- comme des gens normaux.
- Je ne suis pas normal.
Tu es exactement comme ma mère !
Tu te crois supérieur
à tout le monde. Tu sais quoi ?
Parfois, quand on couche
ensemble,
je pense à quelqu'un d'autre.
Je pense à une autre
à chaque fois.
Mary, tu dois te retourner
dans ta tombe.
Comme si son avis m'importait !
Puis elle n'est pas
- morte.
- Quoi ?
Ma mère vit encore. Elle ne peut
pas se retourner dans sa tombe.
J'ai dit que Mary devait
se retourner dans sa tombe.
Tu es débile ?
Elle n'est pas morte. On ne dit ça
que quand les gens sont morts.
- Ta mère s'appelle Mary ?
- Oui. Tu le savais.
Non. Je ne l'aurais pas oublié.
- Maintenant tu le sais.
- Et son nom de jeune fille ?
- Pourquoi ça t'intéresse ?
- Parce que ça m'intéresse !
C'est Lupinski.
Ça va ?
Qu'est-ce que tu as au visage ?
Je croyais t'avoir perdue.
Quoi ?
La vache ! Tu es vraiment
un loup-garou ?
Je suis méchant.
Wayne, non !
Mary ?
Chris !
Chris ?
Elle est en vie.
Merde ! Merde, merde,
merde, merde, merde !
La boulette !
Bonjour.
Mary est là ?
Non, au cinéma.
Sûrement un Woody Allen.
Aucune idée.
- On se connaît ?
- On s'est croisés en ville.
Est-ce qu'elle a
une peau extraordinaire ?
C'est une question bizarre.
Vous auriez une photo d'elle ?
Elle n'aime pas les photos.
Bien sûr. C'est vrai. Désolé.
C'est à elle.
Bien... Merci.
Attends !
Tu croyais Chris morte,
mais elle est encore
en vie. Mary,
qui est morte, est allée
voir un Woody Allen ?
Elle devait être dans le coma
quand on l'a enterrée.
On ne vérifiait pas
le pouls à l'époque.
Si sa mère est un vampire,
- Chris aussi, non ?
- Ça ne marche pas comme ça.
C'est comme l'herpès.
La mère peut être
infectée sans que
son enfant le soit.
Donc une fois ta victime proche
de la mort, tu arrêtes de boire ?
Pour en faire un vampire ? Non,
je bois un demi-litre de son sang.
C'est tout ? C'est ce que
je donne au don du sang.
Tu as les crocs empoisonnés
comme dans Twilight ?
C'est une croyance ridicule.
C'est le fait de boire le sang
qui compte, pas la morsure.
- C'est bête tant c'est simple.
- Si je t'ouvre les veines,
recueille, puis bois ton sang,
demain tu seras un vampire.
Je signe où ?
Je m'en veux pour Chris.
- J'ignore comment ça va finir.
- Comme un conte
de fée, mon vieux. Un conte
de fée qui durera pour toujours.
Je dois être là à son réveil.
Cool ! Je viens.
Merde !
C'est quoi, le pire ?
Il te vole ta chérie ou...
il te vole ta chérie,
puis il la transforme en vampire.
Les deux scénarios craignent.
Les vampires n'existant pas,
je n'ai qu'à m'inquiéter du premier.
Combien de preuves te faut-il ?
Entrez !
Quand on parle du vampire.
Docteur G. ! Qu'est-ce qui vous
amène ici à cette heure tardive ?
Il est 9h30.
L'heure du crime.
Peut-on vous offrir un truc ?
Quelque chose à boire, peut-être ?
Non merci. En fait,
je cherche Chris.
- Chris Keller.
- On connaît son nom de famille.
Certains ici prenaient
des bains avec elle autrefois.
C'est très important.
Regardez dans votre voiture.
Elle y passe beaucoup de temps.
S'il vous plaît,
si vous savez...
Au feu de camp des Lambda
Sigma sur la falaise.
- Que lui voulez-vous ?
- Je veux juste la retrouver.
Tu ne crois toujours pas
que c'est un vampire ?
Seulement un gros connard
doublé d'un fils de pute.
Je vais te présenter Ludmila.
Désolé, mon grand.
Salut, Chris.
- Tu pourrais frapper.
- Tu en as tué combien ?
Avec lui, 29.
J'ai à te parler.
De quoi ?
Tu es un vampire.
Et...
Sans blague ? Vingt-neuf !
Je dois t'enseigner
certaines règles.
Comme ?
Tu dois apprendre à te coiffer
sans miroir.
Comment ne pas exploser
au soleil. Comment ne pas
laisser tes victimes en vie ou
elles deviendront des vampires.
Pourquoi m'as-tu laissée
en vie ?
Parce que je ne te voulais
aucun mal.
Écoute...
Parlons des autres options.
Comme quoi ?
Par exemple,
boire du sang animal.
Tu as eu mon message ?
J'ai goûté cette merde au frigo.
On s'y fait.
Ce n'est pas parce que
tu es faible que je dois l'être.
Je sais que c'est tout frais
pour toi. Ça doit être difficile.
C'est même assez facile.
Aide-moi à nettoyer.
On en parlera après.
Tu sais quoi ? Débrouille-toi.
Putain ! Ce que c'est bon
d'être une rebelle !
On se fait un ciné ?
Mary, où es-tu ?
Ton toast a brûlé.
Je veux divorcer.
Je mérite un smoothie.
J'ai tué un prêtre qui disait
que je n'avais pas d'âme.
J'ai tué un quarterback qui
avait des sentiments pour moi.
Tu étais vraiment
impuissant sans moi ?
Eh bien...
Je l'étais.
Mais ensuite, il m'est arrivé
un truc drôle.
Alors,
pas drôle dans le sens hilarant.
C'était plutôt
drôle dans le sens :
« Voilà qui est intéressant ».
Tu connais Chris ?
Oui. Comment la connais-tu ?
De l'université.
Tu sais que vous vous ressemblez
comme deux gouttes d'eau ?
On pourrait être jumelles.
Oui, donc...
Je disais... Grâce à elle,
mes crocs ont repoussé.
Depuis, on baise.
Mais je ne suis pas amoureux
et on est sur le point de rompre.
J'ai aussi fait d'elle un vampire.
Elle a déjà tué 29 personnes.
Chaque fois, je pensais à toi.
Sors de chez moi.
Va-t'en.
Pars !
Ils préfèrent faire l'amour
pendant la journée.
Ça calme leur peur du soleil.
Après l'orgasme, je les dessine
à chaque fois.
Qu'y a-t-il ?
Vous n'aimez pas le sexe ?
Sans doute que j'adore ça.
Je ne vois pas en quoi votre vie
sexuelle peut nous aider.
Il y a plus de mille dessins
dans ce livre.
S'il a des couilles,
il est dedans.
Des couilles...
Lui aussi, vous avez fait
l'amour avec lui ?
Non, pas avec lui.
Dieu sait que j'ai essayé.
Je l'ai rencontré
à Coney Island en 1986.
Il disait qu'il avait déjà aimé
et que ça lui suffisait.
Il m'a offert un corn-dog .
Son nom ?
Il ne l'a jamais dit.
Mais je me rappelle son surnom.
C'était quoi ?
La Merveille.
- Allons-y.
- J'ai rendez-vous avec elle.
Je te rejoins.
Merci.
- Pose-le là.
- Tu es sûre ?
Hé, les pouffes !
Où sont les autres ?
- Au bowling.
- Trop nul.
- C'est de l'absinthe ?
- Tu ne sais pas ce que tu rates.
Comme vous toutes.
J'ai un truc
qui va vous retourner
le cerveau.
- C'est quoi ?
- Suis-moi.
Où es ton fouet, salope ?
Tu joues les goudous avec moi ?
Approche.
Tu veux des body shots ?
Je suis contente que tu prennes
cette direction.
Moi aussi.
C'est pas vrai !
Quoi ? Vous me remercierez
demain.
C'est bien parti.
Allez !
Rien.
Pourquoi tu lui as dit ?
Je suppose qu'il le fallait.
Fait chier !
Des heures de thérapie
et retour à la case départ.
Tu as les mains fripées.
C'est bizarre sur un vampire.
Sinon... vingt-neuf,
c'est beaucoup ?
Oui, c'est beaucoup.
Tu ne trouves pas ?
- Aucune idée.
- A Toulouse,
un type a fait 19 morts
son premier soir.
- C'est un « Nosferatu Puternic ».
- C'est quoi ?
Un « super vampire » en roumain.
Un tueur de sang froid,
qui tue bien plus
- qu'il boit.
- Il vit encore ?
Non. Il s'est endormi au soleil.
Tu dois l'éliminer,
n'est-ce pas ?
Tu es dingue !
- On doit le tuer, non ?
- Avec la lumière du soleil.
Ainsi on évitera la prison
s'il n'est pas un vampire.
Tu te fous de moi ? Depuis cinq
semaines, tu m'assures que
- c'en est un.
- C'en est un !
Mais je me laisse
le droit à l'erreur.
Docteur G. ! Vous vous êtes
bien foutu de ma gueule.
- Carrément !
- Quoi ?
- Vous m'avez volé ma copine.
- Pardon ?
- On a la preuve en photo.
- Une photo de moi ?
Venez ici pour la voir.
- Donnez !
- Je suis crevé. Je reste là.
Vide !
On a réfléchi le soleil
dans ta sale tronche de vampire.
On me trouve moins
sympa maintenant ?
- Il n'est pas mort, trouduc !
- Je n'ai pas le temps pour ça.
C'est du noyer, idiot.
C'est une blague !
Je n'aurais aucun mal à vous
pulvériser, alors arrêtez !
Parlons.
Jurez de ne pas mordre
mon meilleur ami.
- Pitié, pitié !
- Aucun risque.
Je ne peux pas.
Pas avec tout ce qui se passe
dans ma vie. Asseyez-vous.
Pas sur vos sièges à baiser.
Dans ce cas, appuyez-vous
quelque part.
Je suis bien debout.
Faites ce qui vous chante.
J'ai une annonce difficile
à vous faire. Il vaut mieux être
assis quand vous l'entendrez.
Pire que d'apprendre que votre
prof préféré est un vampire
qui baise comme un dingue
avec votre âme sœur ?
- Pire.
- Vous l'avez tuée ?
Non ! J'en ai fait un vampire...
qu'on doit maintenant tuer.
Bâtard !
Je sais. Je ne suis qu'un bâtard.
Un fils de pute.
Et un gros enculé.
Je n'ai jamais souhaité ça.
Mais elle est hors de contrôle
et je dois l'arrêter.
Comment ?
Je l'ignore encore.
Besoin d'aide ?
Bande de salauds.
Elle est canon et tout, mais...
tu ne lui plaisais pas tant
que ça et maintenant c'est...
- Un démon des enfers !
- J'ai dit :
« Bande de salauds ! »
On vous écoute.
Pourquoi du frêne ?
Je l'ignore. Pourquoi j'explose
au soleil ?
Pourquoi je reste allergique
aux cacahuètes ?
Après avoir tué Chris,
on passe à vous ?
Je comprendrais.
- Car vous êtes un vampire.
- Mais il est différent.
Parce qu'il aime coucher avec
des ados et en faire des vampires ?
Je suis différent
parce que je n'aime pas tuer.
Sauf vos ex.
Coïncidence.
Si vous en êtes un depuis plus
longtemps, vous êtes plus fort ?
Affrontez-la tout seul.
Je suis impuissant.
Les vampires combattent
avec leur zizi ?
Je vous assure que j'ai
des érections phénoménales.
Je peux maintenir une érection.
Je veux dire que je ne peux pas
me transformer en vampire.
Je n'arrive pas
à sortir mes crocs.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce que vous êtes un connard ?
C'est une longue histoire.
Mais même si je pouvais,
elle est plus forte que moi.
J'ai vu sa force le premier soir.
Et ce n'était que le début.
Dites plutôt que
vous êtes faible.
Je ne suis pas faible.
Elle est plus forte.
Les vampires font-ils tout
dans le crottin et la neige ?
On fait tout dans le crottin
et la neige.
Tu l'as lu
dans le Guide du Vampire ?
- Je disais ça comme ça.
- C'est le seul endroit ombragé.
Je la maintiendrai au sol
car ce sera le plus difficile.
Toi, tiens le pieu en place
et appuie-toi dessus.
Parce que je suis lourd ?
Pour aider, d'accord ?
Fred, prépare ta massue.
Bien au-dessus du cœur.
Fais gaffe à mes doigts.
Frappe fort.
Les vampires ont les os
très durs.
On n'a pas droit à l'erreur.
Cloue cette salope au sol.
C'est ma salope.
Espèce d'enculé.
Comment on sort d'ici, bordel ?
Allez vous faire foutre
avec votre portail
de merde !
Je vous hais !
Si tu fais ça le jour J,
on est mal barrés.
C'est dur pour nous tous.
Facile à dire pour vous.
Elle devait être ma dulcinée.
La collecte de sang
est obligatoire. Elle aura
lieu à la résidence des STD.
Où est Chris ?
Elle devrait être là.
A la résidence ? Mais comment ?
Le camion sera garé devant.
Ils auront le matériel dont
ils ont besoin. À nous
de fournir les en-cas
pour les donneurs.
Je viens d'avoir un frisson.
Où étiez-vous ?
On a tué un employé de station-
service. Il a fallu nettoyer.
Hilarant.
Ça l'était.
Mon Dieu !
Réunion reportée.
Alors, qui veut devenir
un vampire ?
Allons ! Ne soyez pas timides.
Bien. Les autres serviront
de dîner.
Tirons-nous.
Je vous cherchais.
Fred voulait raisonner Chris.
- Alors ?
- Que lui avez-vous fait ?
Elle change les filles
de sa sororité en vampires.
Seulement la moitié.
Elles vont manger les autres.
- On aura besoin d'aide.
- Qui nous aiderait ?
Bonjour.
Bonjour, Mary.
Je remarquais justement à quel
point tes fleurs sont belles.
Des chrysanthèmes.
J'aime beaucoup.
Tu as de très bons goûts.
Comment connais-tu Fred Green ?
Il nous aide
pour la logistique de...
notre plan pour tuer Chris.
Elle a transformé sa sororité
en vampires. Elle est forte.
Très forte.
Pourquoi lui as-tu infligé ça ?
Vois-tu, la vie nous fait
parfois de drôles
de surprises.
Mais là, ça n'en est pas une,
comme tu le sais.
J'ai bien merdé.
Pourquoi m'as-tu enterrée ?
Je ne savais pas.
J'ai besoin de ton aide.
Fred est un vampire ?
- Non, il file un coup de main.
- Il va se faire tuer.
On travaille sur
un plan d'attaque.
Je ne vous aiderai pas à tuer
ma fille. Impossible.
Je m'en doutais.
J'ai ta bénédiction ?
Bon...
Dis-moi bonne chance.
Je risque d'y rester.
J'avais faim. Je me suis arrêté
pour acheter un burrito.
J'arrive bientôt.
On peut dire les deux, vieux.
Maman.
- Chris.
- Salut, Tom.
Il doit pleuvoir ?
Dommage,
je n'ai pas pensé à emmener
mon parapluie.
Alors...
Je vois que vous avez toutes
le vôtre ouvert.
- On se protège la peau.
- Très judicieux.
Que suis-je censé faire
aujourd'hui ? C'est quoi ?
C'est pour le don de sang.
Tu n'es pas au courant ?
Si, mais je supposais
que c'était annulé.
Pourquoi ?
La météo.
C'est pour le cancer de la peau.
Désolé.
Empêche Fred de venir.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je suis sûre
qu'il a un souffle au cœur.
Mais toi, viens.
Je vois le genre.
Je dois aller en cours.
Si tu veux bien m'excuser.
Si on m'avait dit il y a quatre
mois qu'à la fin du semestre,
je conspirerais pour tuer
l'amour de ma vie
car c'est un vampire psychotique,
j'aurais répondu :
« N'importe quoi ! »
Mais maintenant que
ça se produit,
je repense à ce scénario
improbable et...
j'ai envie de me secouer et
de me dire : « Écoute ce type.
Il sait parfaitement
de quoi il parle. »
Salope !
Désolé.
Tu as vu un fantôme ?
Plutôt des vampires qui essaient
de me tuer, avec ma fraternité.
- Une collecte de sang.
- C'est maintenu ?
Oui, elles distribuent
des tracts.
Chris te déconseille de venir
à cause de ton souffle au cœur.
Je n'en ai pas.
Alors c'est une menteuse,
en plus.
C'est insensé.
Écoutez... Ça ne change rien
à nos projets.
Ça nous indique où les trouver.
Réfléchissons.
Ça va aller.
Vous vouliez me voir ?
Bonjour !
J'ai dit à Chris que je ne pouvais
pas venir donner mon sang,
puis j'ai réalisé que...
j'étais égoïste.
- C'est votre sang ?
- En effet.
Ça suffira ? J'ai la tête
qui tourne légèrement.
Pouvez-vous vous assurer
qu'il parvienne à Chris ? Je pense
qu'elle saura quoi en faire.
Certainement.
Bien.
Je crois que je vais me coucher
de bonne heure ce soir.
Vous dormez là ?
Vous n'imaginez pas à quel point
ce machin est confortable.
Ne buvez pas avant de conduire.
- Tu as fini ?
- Oui.
Dépêchons-nous. Le salon ferme
plus tôt le vendredi.
Les siamois débiles !
C'est quoi, ce truc ?
Un porte-manteau.
Avec des crochets jusqu'au sol ?
Pour les enfants.
C'est interdit aux gosses ici.
Virez-moi ça avant la soirée.
Pas si vite !
On vient s'installer.
Tu es là ?
C'est qu'il se passe des trucs
que même en rêve, on croirait
- impossibles.
- Les Kappa O ! Ça roule ?
Salut, Kyle.
Cool ! Vous êtes habillées
comme des putes.
On doit y aller.
- Alors tu ne seras pas là ?
- Tu veux que je sois là ?
Dans les deux cas,
ça n'a pas d'importance.
- Donc c'est comme ça ?
- Comme quoi ?
Il est vraiment temps
qu'on y aille. Excusez-nous.
Mes amis, la famille.
Ludmila.
C'est peut-être la dernière fois
que vous me voyez en vie.
Je vous aime et je fais ça
pour vous.
Quant à vous, les Kappa O,
bouclez vos ceintures. On va vous
expédier tout droit en enfer.
Vous avez fini de vous peloter ?
- Presque.
- C'est quoi, ce chantier ?
C'est ce que c'est.
On a besoin de vous en haut.
La cuisine est dégueulasse.
Si vous faites un effort, peut-
être que vous baiserez ce soir.
Avec des filles, pour une fois.
Je t'en supplie.
Aide-moi à la tuer.
Pas question.
J'ai un double appel.
Tu patientes ?
Ça en est où ?
Là, Fred fait un peu chier,
mais on ne devrait pas tarder.
Entendu.
Je dois y aller.
Si tu changes d'avis,
on sera en train de s'entre-tuer
au 1637 sur Benton.
Voilà. Au revoir.
Elle se moque que je sois là.
Une fois, elle veut me tuer ;
une autre, non. Je ne pige rien.
Elle compte te tuer
depuis le début.
Mais elle prétend s'en foutre car
elle veut te garder pour elle.
- Ce n'est pas toi...
- Cachez-vous.
Dites aux filles
que c'est l'heure.
On est là pour la nuit donc
ne vous faites pas prendre.
- Où est passée Mel ?
- Cette fête est de plus en plus
- pourrie.
- Calme-toi.
Elles ont dit : « Dehors, don du
sang. La soirée, c'est dedans. »
- On s'en fout, on sort.
- Tu crois quoi ?
Que je vais courir partout ?
Les gars ! Elles ne vont pas
venir, ces salopes.
- Canons !
- Comment tu me trouves ?
On était censés
bien s'habiller ?
Salut, les filles !
Ça roule ?
- Vous avez des dents de dracula.
- Sans déconner !
- Comment ça tient ?
- Comme les tiennes, neuneu !
On monte ?
Je veux te faire voir un truc.
J'adorerais,
mais Carly avait dit prem's.
Ça pose un problème ?
Loin de là !
Allons-y.
Si vous voulez peloter
un vampire, levez la main.
Moi ! Choisissez-moi !
Voilà ce qu'on va faire.
Toi, monte avec cette fille
et fais-lui l'amour. Attention,
je n'ai pas dit « baiser ».
Et toi, mon grand, viens ici
et emmène cette fille-là.
Non. Pas toi, connard.
Bien. J'ouvrirai la fenêtre
de l'intérieur.
Vous volerez jusque là ?
Je suis peut-être balèze, mais
pas à ce point-là. Je grimperai.
Bon. On est prêts à y aller ?
Tu es prêt à planter un pieu
dans le cœur de ton grand amour ?
Rajoutes-en une couche.
Il essaie de te mettre
dans le bon état d'esprit.
On ne peut pas hésiter.
On a mis des heures
à installer ça et toi...
Comme tu es en colère...
Mais défoule-toi...
Je ferai ce qu'il faut.
Reste à espérer que
personne n'atterrisse là.
Tu as un problème ?
- J'ai horreur des croche-pieds.
- Désolée.
- C'est interdit aux filles.
- J'ai vu des Kappa O entrer.
C'est une soirée Kappa O-STD.
Pour changer.
Dommage, tu viens de mourir.
Jared, tu avais dit qu'il y en
aurait pour tout le monde.
C'est ce que j'ai dit
parce que c'est vrai.
Vu que tu m'as bien baisé...
Je te jure que je vais
m'occuper de toi.
Je suis un chef réglo,
je ne me suis pas servi.
Où sont-elles ?
Quoi ? Regardez nos deux
bouffons parés pour le bal
- des bouffons.
- Où sont les Kappa O ?
On y aura tous droit.
Vous aussi, si vous vous asseyez
et arrêtez vos gamineries.
Bande de cons ! C'est des
vampires. Elles vont nous tuer.
Ouais ! C'est chaud.
- Où est Kyle ?
- En train de s'en taper une.
Non, ne monte pas.
Tu vas lui casser son coup.
C'est quoi ?
C'est une barricade, ducon !
Personne ne sort tant qu'on n'a
pas tué tous les vampires.
Kyle, tu es là ? Ouvre !
Je suis occupé.
Elle va te tuer !
- Tu peux être le prochain.
- Gourmande !
Bien. Visez le cœur et frappez
avec un truc lourd.
Libre à toi de ne pas baiser,
mais ne grille pas les autres.
Kyle est avec l'une d'elles.
On doit le sauver.
Mec, par curiosité,
est-ce que tu es gay ?
Ça ne change rien
pour moi, mais...
Je vais t'exploser la queue.
Il y a ici des vampires
qui veulent nous tuer.
Si vous en voyez une, plaquez-la
au sol et faites le nécessaire.
Voilà où je veux en venir !
Attends.
J'enlève quand mon pantalon ?
Quand je serai partie.
Mince !
C'est parti !
Saloperie !
- Tu ne m'auras pas.
- Je parie que si.
Vérifions quand même.
Attends !
Mords-moi à sa place.
Ta jugulaire est plus facile
à trouver ?
Quoi ?
Que dois-je faire ?
Dis-moi clairement
ce que je dois faire.
Ça fait mal ?
C'est officiel.
On est des meurtriers.
On s'y fait.
- Quoi ?
- Les assassins.
Ils s'habituent à...
Ne me regarde pas comme ça.
C'est mon premier meurtre.
Je te jure.
Comment conserve-t-on le sang ?
Vous êtes bien curieuse.
J'aimerais organiser
une collecte de sang un jour.
Elles font sûrement pipi,
mais caca, ça m'étonnerait.
- Salut, Fred.
- Salut.
Tu es au courant qu'on prend
toutes du bon temps avec vous ?
C'est ce qu'on raconte.
Dommage que Chris
t'ait réservé pour elle.
Elle s'en fiche, non ?
Ça ne serait que des bisous.
Je veux m'amuser avec toi,
mais dans mon lit.
Je peux mater ?
C'est notre truc.
J'aime mater.
Ça roule, les tordus.
Bien, dans ce cas...
C'est par ici.
Le sang fait pfff !
On commence les câlins ?
Tu ne veux pas t'allonger ?
Je m'installerai sur toi.
Tu as déjà tout planifié,
n'est-ce pas ?
- On a un système bien rodé.
- Je me couche.
C'est mieux.
Que faites-vous là ?
Je récupère mon frisbee.
- Vous jouez à l'ultimate ?
- Non.
Maggie ne jouait pas non plus.
Elle ne s'en remet pas.
Venez voir.
Oups !
Vérifions quand même.
Ça a l'air bien.
Prenez une chambre.
Pas de bisous dans le cou,
il est chatouilleux.
Ce n'était pas prévu.
Maintenant !
Descends de là.
Entre les seins !
Où est Chris ?
Bon sang !
On ne l'a pas vue.
Vous m'avez fait peur.
Plus tard, pétasses.
Maman ?
Pourquoi me haïssez-vous,
mon Dieu ?
Les débiles !
- J'ai vu ce que vous avez fait.
- À Samantha aussi ?
Non. Tu as vu
ce qu'on a fait à Jared ?
Il est juste là.
Alors, tu as vu ?
Attrape Fred. Tue Tom.
Du noyer, zut !
Viens, Tom. Ça sera beaucoup
plus drôle si tu ne résistes pas.
Vous réalisez que
c'est l'échec assuré ?
- C'est qui ?
- Chris.
Ouvrez la porte.
Retenez-le.
- Il y a une barricade.
- Enlevez-la !
Tu fais pervers,
avec ton énorme appareil photo.
Quoi ?
Sans ça, je t'aurais
sans doute invité
- au bal de l'hiver.
- Tu es sérieuse ?
Mais maintenant,
je vais te vider de ton sang.
Attends ! Attends !
Tu veux savoir
ce que j'aurais répondu ?
Quoi ?
Va te faire voir, pétasse !
Purge-toi.
Désolé.
J'aurais sûrement accepté.
Désolé, les filles.
Dépêchez-vous d'ouvrir.
- Madame Keller ?
- Fred Green ? C'est bien toi ?
- Que faites-vous là ?
- La même chose que vous.
Vous venez tuer Chris ?
Tu l'as trouvé.
Tu t'es teint les cheveux.
Regardez ce qu'a fait Fred.
Retire-le, abrutie.
Je voulais d'abord
vous le montrer.
Jolie coloration.
C'est la mère de Chris.
Venez vous battre.
Passez-moi un pieu !
Tout de suite !
Allez, Fred ! Fais-le.
Empale-la.
- Je l'ai.
- Je me rends ! Je me rends !
- Attendez !
- Elle ment.
Je le sais.
J'ai une meilleure idée.
Ç'aurait été bête de ne pas
s'en servir. Où est Tom ?
Ne résiste pas.
Elle était amoureuse de moi.
Il est mort.
Merde !
Devinez qui a tué l'infirmière
et volé le sang.
Pourquoi voler le sang ?
C'est un super vampire.
Elle va boire tout le stock.
Dans quel but ?
Pour changer les donneurs
en vampires.
La salope !
Une salope très bien.
On doit l'arrêter, non ?
- Rien ne t'oblige à faire ça.
- Je crois que si.
Rassure-toi. Quand on y repensera
dans quelques siècles,
on en rira.
- Pour l'heure, c'est tragique.
- Finissons-en.
Je suis là !
Que fais-tu ?
Je coupe le sang au Monster.
D'où vient-il ?
A ton avis ?
Je t'ai vue passer en voiture.
Il faut qu'on parle.
Je t'écoute.
À quoi te sert ce sang ?
Je crée des vampires.
Ce n'est pas sorcier !
Ces personnes ont une vie.
Qui durera pour toujours.
Tu es diabolique.
Je ne suis pas faible.
J'adore tuer.
Et j'adore pousser des gens
à en tuer d'autres. Ça m'éclate.
Pitié, tuez-moi !
C'est la conversation la plus
chiante de ma vie.
Je suis désolée.
Tout est de ma faute.
Maintenant !
Elle me mord.
Mary, le pieu ! Vite !
Vas-y ! Dans le cœur.
Je ne peux pas.
Poule mouillée !
Joli...
Joli coup.
Je suis vraiment désolé.
- Ça ne fait rien.
- Jamais
je ne t'aurais tuée
si tu n'étais pas un vampire.
Je le sais.
Moi, je t'aurais tué.
Mais pas avant de
t'avoir donné ceci.
J'ai fait une compilation
pour ton iPod.
Elle est sur cette clé USB.
Tu me l'aurais donnée
avant de me tuer ?
J'aurais tiré à pile ou face.
Je l'écouterai quand je courrai.
Tu es ce qui m'est
arrivé de mieux.
Merci.
Maman ?
Oui, ma puce ?
Tu n'es pas une poule mouillée.
J'ai rêvé qu'on avait tué Chris.
Merde ! On a tué Chris.
Elle m'a fait une compilation.
Laisse-le.
- Allons voir le frigo.
- Je n'ai pas faim.
Ou pour un truc léger.
Un yaourt, par exemple.
Ou un parfait.
Il n'y a que du sang
et des Monster.
Je vais prendre une Monster.
Vous en voulez ?
On va avoir d'autres
vampires à tuer.
Combien ?
L'enfoiré !